the i-team has obtained 9-1-1 calls at
the center of a murder case good evening
i'm brian loftis and i'm denise valdez a
16-year-old girl and her 18-year-old
boyfriend are accused of killing her
father
and we're now hearing the moments
leading up to police discovering the
victim's body
the i-team's vanessa murphy live in the
newsroom at six with the story
[Music]
brian the first call we're hearing is
from the victim daniel held says mother
to police
she explains he's been missing for a
couple of days that's not like him
and his debit card was used at three
different atms
she also mentions his daughter wasn't
answering her calls
the second is from a caller who says
he's discovered the body inside the home
both of them
are tough to hear a mother looking for
her son
and a caller who found the burnt body
he's been missing for two days his
work's called
his family's called i've called his
ex-wife's called
and there's nobody answering the phone
and nobody
is there's there's nothing i know
there's something very wrong going on
here
but there's a dead body in the garage we
just found them with the homeowner that
doesn't live here
okay and you're in there right now yes
that call was made on april 9. metro
police have told the
eye team the teens tried to dismember 45
year old daniel halseth
his daughter 16 year old sierra halseth
and her boyfriend
18 year old aaron guerrero were later
arrested
in salt lake city utah they are both now
in custody here in clark county
they face murder charges and are
expected to appear in court tomorrow
reporting live in the newsroom vanessa
murphy 8 news now